Promises are built into a lot of
things in the browser like,
fetch and getUserMedia. We're
starting to see libraries
implement promises on their own,
and it's probably a good idea
for you to implement promises
into your own code base. To
create your own promise, you
create a variable, and you store
a new promise inside of it. A
promise constructor takes one
function here, which passes you
resolve and reject. The idea
here is that your promise is
either going to resolve, which
means it finishes and passes
data back to you. For example,
when we used the JSON API, When
the data actually came back, it
resolved itself and it passed us
a list of my blog posts. Or it
could reject itself, because
maybe there was an error or the
data was malformed, or for
whatever reason you'd like to
reject the actual promise and
that will error on out.
We've got these two things right
here, and you just call them
when you are ready to finish
this promise. I'm going to
call one immediately, and we're
going to pass is like "Wes is
cool," because that's the data
for this promise. Then we go
ahead and say p, and we say .
then. I'm just going to do it on
its own line here -- it's no
different than doing that, but
just for readability sake -- p.
then. That's going to pass us
some data, which in turn we'd be
able to console.log the actual
data. Let's see what happens
here when we reload. Immediately
we see "Wes is cool." Why?
Because we created a promise and
then just immediately resolved
it by passing back "Wes is cool."
It's really not that useful, but
what you can probably see is
that if we wanted to resolve
something after some amount of
time, maybe after some
processing has been done...
Maybe you wanted to do some
processing on the background
that's really intensive. Maybe
you wanted to do an AJAX request
in the background, and then when
the data comes back to you.
There's a whole bunch of
different use cases for when you
would want to use a promise.
Essentially it all boils down to "
I don't want to stop JavaScript
from running, I just want to
start this thing, and then when
it comes back I'll deal with the
actual result." Let's see what
happens when we put a set
timeout on here. Maybe after one
second, we're going to see that
we're going to resolve it. There
we go, one second later, "Wes is
cool" pops up. You'll notice
that it doesn't pop up
immediately. Similarly, we
could also call reject on it.
Look at this, uncaught, in
promise, "Wes is cool." That's
the actual error. Maybe we'll
change that to say, "Error, Wes
isn't cool." Why is that
uncaught in promise? Because we
didn't catch it, right? We
should catch the error, and then
we'll do console.error. The
actual error there, and now when
we refresh this after a second,
there we go. That is a caught
one on line 20. One thing
that you might notice is that it
tells us Line 20, but that's
where we caught the error.
Obviously that is where we
caught it, but didn't the error
actually happen on Line 11? Why
doesn't it say anything about
Line 11 in here? Ideally
what you do is you throw in an
error object, not just a string,
so we'll wrap that sucker in an
error object, and then when it
console.logs the error, we see
that we have information about
where it happened. It happened
in the timeout on Line 11.